[Music]
invent anything and there's no
boundaries at all no boundaries I think
I would invent this a super braid so
that when I went swimming I could use as
a snorkel so I could breathe underwater
but when I wanted to fly I could use it
as like a truffle so I would start
flying and I could also like connected
to things to it like download
information so you're not just like a
multi super brave I think well
I would invent a robot that does your
homework cuz I'm tired of it we need to
stop doing homework some sort of glove
in order to attach my phone to it to
just slide it and lock it and slide it
back for your phone case that would just
be like so it'll be in your hand and
then you would be able to slide it up
and lock it and it would be able to run
around with it and walk it and slide it
back I would invent general AI I'd be
pretty me that I should have like these
machines that would kind of like help us
but surpass us in a way like it'd be
really a reality check to check like
religion art science and it affected all
differently walks of life and people's
like it may start some like some Wars
but I think it may be worth it yeah it
would be scary I'd be scared there's way
too many feelings planet already so
probably a machine that would decide
fairly among all the people on the
planet who we would eat that way we'd
have sustainable food
unless overpopulation and they could be
a really good thing I can't come up with
so much
that's always probably some some kind of
like jumper that'll make me like fly so
I could fly somewhat so I could fly to
allies we wouldn't have to drive that
it's a good fight through Poland so
we'll have to fly it on the plate which
is very annoying and yeah way to quit
working in Georgia all the time I'd say
an automatic back scratcher I'm big into
having my back scratched I think I'd be
good for me in the world I would invent
a realistic solution to climate change
like a rising fee on carbon emissions
that kind of stimulates the economy in
the job market
maybe having the revenue all returned to
American households from that carbon tax
kind of like one that citizens climate
Lobby does I would make something that
makes my life decisions for me I'm very
indecisive an asset tells me where the
nearest ice cream man is yeah I would
invent the ability to be able to see
loved ones that are no longer here I
lost my grandmother last year and I wish
every day I could still talk to her I
probably would have been something too
save children from getting healed in
these cars as they are closing you know
as people get out forget that they're in
there so I'll probably bid something
I always go back and change something
that you regret invisibility so I can
see back the time machine just to go
back in time always wanted to be a
Renaissance girl so a car that can only
can fly but also go in water and it also
can like you can shrink it so it becomes
smaller so it can fit in tighter places
it's almost like a transformer I guess
something so the dinner doesn't get cold
when I'm eating at a restaurant like the
plate stays hot you plug it into the
table everywhere I go I want the food to
stay calm I like be good okay so some
earbuds that I could meet my co-workers
but still hear my phone ringing so I
wouldn't miss it
it'd be cool to pioneer a martial art
something that could change babies
diapers for me that would be awesome it
would be in medicine in the field of
medicine and it would have to do with
premature babies and knowing more and
understanding more about some of the
diseases
in particular neck which is a intestinal
disease and I don't know I haven't read
on it recently but there was a time
where they didn't know much about it or
what caused it or you know how to
resolve it other than just like removing
part of the intestine so I think that
there surely has to be a better way
probably an app like a new app to buy
weed
yeah delivery delivery service and
that's patented Michael don't try to
steal my idea something to prevent the
flooding that has happened whether it's
the weather or something on land oh I
would invent something that would make
you focus 24/7 so you can get good
grades I did invent something that like
reads to see if someone's lying that's
on your phone it could be like it
half-done be so sick hi like record what
they're saying would be like if they're
like the cure for Alzheimer's or cancer
diseases and I mentioned the cure cancer
mind really would be to cure cancer
because my father night after lung
cancer so mine truly would be cancer
because it's touched my life so I think
that there is a cure for cancer
it's very highly regulated because
people make a lot of money off of
different medications like chemo I'm a
nurse so I think that that is a reality
and a lot of things we do in the world
revolve around money and so I I don't
know it be necessarily needs like an
invention but maybe I don't know
like awareness
[Music]